# Free videos on iTunes! (and changes at Patreon)
Hello Internet
From today I will make my videos available for free on iTunes. If you click this link
you can get them downloaded automatically to your phone or tablet or computer. - and
Yes, before thousands of people ask about it in the comments, there is an RSS feed that nerds like you
insert anywhere.
I'd like you to click on the screen to try it, because it's something like that
I always wanted to make available. Partly because it is easy for you and also because
YouTube as the only home for my videos is a bit scary. Certainly lately.
So, this is a safe place for the videos where I pay to host them so YouTube
has no control over it. That's pretty important.
It is possible for me to offer this for free partly because a number of videos
have a sponsor message at the end.
I tell you this before the next video because the other important reason I am trying is this
is for your direct support to Patreon.
It is these 2 things that allow videos to exist independently of YouTube
without me, from the maker's point of view,
shoots myself in the foot.
But I am also concerned that some of you, my dearest crowd funders, sponsored videos
would not support. If you are such a person, don't worry. Everything is cool - that's exactly
the reason I made what you are looking at now: to let you know in advance.
And of course, every time I talk about "crowd-funding" I want to be super clear that there are many
are people who should not support. And then I look at you,
students etc.
For everything else, crowd funding should feel like offering me coffee via the internet because
you like the things i make. And I love coffee. It is not an obligation.
The crowd funding, however, ensures that I can make videos out of interest
and convenience and not just because of the popularity. And it also allows for all kinds of things
put out advertisements that I think are intrusive, such as pups I hate and you certainly do.
OK, if you still follow, there are some new extras at Patreon - I got it
wallpaper package expanded with new VOTE ANIMAL and other wallpapers, there is a thank you page
on my website and a special extra for spoiler-loving grammar nazis. You know who you are.
So that's the most important thing today: crowdfunding + sponsors = CGP Gray videos on iTunes and
RSS. Click here to try it out and let me know what you think. I am very curious
how this all works for you.
Don't let me know in the comments what you think, they are clearly useless,
tell me on Reddit - where I can really follow the conversation.